If you've seen Logan in the movie theatre
you might have got to see the secret Deadpool
2 teaser which plays just before the main
movie.
It's a fun little short that gives us some
nice easter eggs for the Merc With The Mouth's
upcoming sequel.
The scene isn't part of the main Logan movie,
so I won't be discussing Logan spoilers in
this video, but obviously there are spoilers
for the Deadpool teaser and speculation about
Deadpool 2.
If you prefer, you can check out my spoiler-free
review of Logan here and come back and watch
this video after you've seen the teaser.
The scene begins with Ryan Reynolds as Wade
Wilson walking past an alley where an old
man is being held up at gunpoint.
He pulls down his hoodie, shakes his head
and says "not on my watch, motherfucker" and
runs to a phone booth opposite a movie theatre
which just happens to be playing Logan.
After he gets into the phone booth, John Williams'
Superman theme starts up and he begins to
change out of his regular clothes into his
Deadpool costume.
Cries and pleas for help come from the man
being mugged as Wade struggles hilariously
to get into his suit.
All the while the epic Superman theme is playing
and there's a cheekily amusing moment where
Ryan Reynolds presses his bare butt up against
the phone booth glass.
Just as Wade's almost finished, there's a
loud gunshot followed by silence.
Deadpool finishes getting dressed as quick
as he can, exits the booth and runs slo-mo
across the street to the rising Superman anthem.
When he reaches the guy who's been shot, the
theme cuts out and Deadpool jokes about spending
way too long in the phone booth.
Deadpool then decides to lie down and rest
his head on the dead guy and starts eating
a tub of the man's ice cream.
Deadpool is his usual meta-wisecracking self
in this teaser, making jokes about how weird
it is there's a phone booth on the street,
how he should have used his cell phone to
ring 911, and how other superheroes get changed
so quickly.
He also pokes fun at Logan who he says probably
would have saved the dead guy as he doesn't
have to change into anything as his costume's
just a tank top and jeans.
And as he eats the ice cream he says "ow,
brain freeze", a possible little nod to X-Men:
Apocalypse's deleted "brain freeze" scene
where Nightcrawler thinks he's frozen his
brain after drinking an iced drink.
The words "Deadpool Coming Not Soon Enough"
then appear on screen followed by a scrolling
screen of text in which we get a Deadpool-style
commentary on Ernest Hemmingway's Pulitzer
prize-winning novel "The Old Man And The Sea",
complete with references to the Fresh Prince
and Marilyn Monroe.
So, that was the scene; now, let's jump back
to some easter eggs snuck in around the phone
booth.
First up is some graffiti which reads "Nathan
Summers Cumming Soon!"
scrawled on the phone booth.
This is a big tease to Cable who we know is
in Deadpool 2 and perhaps a hint that we'll
have a casting announcement soon.
Recent news claims that David Harbour who
played Chief Jim Hopper in Strangers Things
has screen-tested for the role alongside Ryan
Reynolds.
Michael Shannon was apparently also in the
running but dropped out because of scheduling
issues.
There's also speculation that Cable might
be played by Pierce Brosnan after Ryan Reynolds
shared a photo of himself with Brosnan and
Hugh Jackman earlier this year.
For anyone who doesn't know, Cable is the
son of Cyclops and Jean Grey-clone Madelyne
Pryor, and he's a time-travelling mutant cyborg
with a cybernetic eye, bionic arms, superhuman
strength, and telepathic and telekinetic powers.
In the comics, Cable also established the
X-Force, basically an off-shoot of the X-Men,
so he could be tied in with that movie too
once it gets off the ground.
By the way, there's also some graffiti which
reads "REY" on the movie theatre behind the
phone booth, probably a little nod to Reynolds
himself.
And when Deadpool emerges from the booth,
you can also spot some Firefly posters.
Although Reynolds was in a 2008 movie called
"Fireflies in the Garden", it's more likely
a reference to Morena Baccarin who starred
in Firefly and played Vanessa in Deadpool.
So, guys what do you think of the Deadpool
short?
And how hyped are you for Deadpool 2 and who
do you think should be cast as Cable?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
Also check out my latest X-Men video with
the 23 coolest easter eggs and X-Men connections
in Logan, plus I'm giving away some awesome
Logan merch on that video.
If you enjoyed this, do hit those like and
subscribe buttons.
Plus you can tap or click here for other videos
you might like!
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers.